if the condom isn't near the bed it's an
erection there's the likelihood is it
isn't a red giant killer you know I'm
gonna touch I'm gonna touch on something
that I've wanted to talk about for ages
and I'm gonna probably gonna bring up on
another one you Iraq tile dysfunction
yeah Wow
so guys at university it is normal it is
absolutely normal for you to not be able
to get it up when you're pissed it's
absolute you know if you not be able to
get it up when it's in your head that
you can't get it up as well but to me
uni I think it was maybe my third year
and I was absolutely blind drunk out of
my mind drunk couldn't get it up when I
went back with a girl
and then that started to become a
self-referential echo chamber that was
like okay now I've only had a couple of
drinks
oh god that problem might happen again
then it does and then it gets to this
stage where you like oh [ __ ] maybe this
is gonna start happening when I'm sober
and sure enough it actually does and
you're like right okay
I need to break the spell of this
somehow and it's really really difficult
and I've I've got a number of friends
who have this has been a cascade into a
really really horrible situation and all
that it needed was someone to say this
which is it is perfectly normal to not
be able to get it to when you're pissed
and if you laugh it off she'll laugh it
off as well and if you're a girl it
doesn't matter if it's never happened to
you before it's not about you it's about
the amount of alcohol that he's had to
drink and if it happens be gracious
about it and just say don't worry you're
not the first like because that is just
gonna make him go oh I thank God for
that
yeah that makes me feel so much about it
because at 19 20 years old thinking I've
got a reptile dysfunction crushing it's
[ __ ] terrible did it happen to you
it's like this I can make up the time
yeah and you get a little psych it's
there it's the thought it's the
split-second of God as much as you've
given people the safety couch to just to
stop with the safety valve to stop that
happening and if it happens in the
moment you've given both men and women a
way to there you go just a lovely reason
it happens it's the it's the
antagonistic reaction to being relaxed
so I it requires relaxation you are
creating anxiety and stress so
interesting mnemonic very useful that is
point and shoot
so parasympathetic nervous system
regulates erection and sympathetic
nervous system which is the Firefly
regulates ejaculation and so P point s
shoot no yes yeah I think you know that
deep deep breaths right breast yeah I
just concede the fact that like if you
if you put 10 pints and a bunch of shots
into yourself and you've been dating on
a bank holiday Sunday or something mmm
like there are men across the world that
this happens - yeah and the problem that
you have is that you don't know that
it's that comment yeah especially when
you're that age I think and you're
terrified of society so Mike my
experience happened like a few times at
uni and I remember thinking like wow I
got really hooked on Oh happens again
but it just takes a few conversations
and people as you get T 20s and
everyone's I use and I are actually
faucet on this is really common yeah but
you know one when you're 18 19 no one
must be the first person exactly to
raise it yeah guys I'm struggling to
maintain my agility and during coitus so
that good tip in the condoms so I I saw
a patient who was stapling they're not
the state do people that was a joke do
not stay Polly Klaas saw a patient who
freshers week was a virgin have sex with
one woman didn't use a condom got HIV
[Music]
like yeah
it is bro so you just you don't know who
using I think it was a man yeah it had
sex a moment is like this and the thing
is transmission rates female to male or
lower than male to female this is
something else girls it's like just
ultimate unlucky wait girls if you are
if you are listening your childhood
color snitch didn't ask me your your
chance of catching an HIV catching at
HIV catching an STI as a girl because of
the shape of your sexual organs
we just think what happens like you you
have a receptacle in your pelvis where
and people are shooting things into it
like possibly infected things
that's oddly z-direction just play that
small segment back to your seller is
gonna be that that's gonna be the pre
you have a ring you have a receptacle
[ __ ] hell
so yeah I think